so when I'm advising companies on what
kind of on pricing and payment plans and
how to think about monetization
strategies again asking them hey is this
a big enough market that freemium will
sort of work where a small percentage
conversion of a large pool like will
make sense for this to be a large
company and so you can just work the
math backwards to make that word most of
them have usually questions about
pricing just like what do I start
charging the Sun so the first comparison
is like do you have competitors charging
to this where do they charge how does
this sort of work if you are thinking
about enterprise companies the way who
usually do is try to figure out like
well how much money is the company
already spending on whatever it is to
solve this problem usually you're not
solving a problem that nobody's working
on it's usually like some problem it
already exists in the company and like
you have a better way of doing it and so
the companies that will do poorly in our
enterprise is when there is no budget
carved out for solving a specific
problem so if there's no budget curve
that it is like almost impossible to
figure out how to generate money out of
thin air like people can only spend
money that is all allocated to them by
the division the company whatever the
finances are at hand then the next thing
is you just say like you know how do you
calculate how much money to spend on it
so you just start off with like well how
many people is dedicated the test what
is the average salary for those people
how much time is spent and you can
figure out there and that's like your
upper bound right and those people are
already working on the problem so you
can't just charge that upper bound right
to begin with because basically you're
saying like those people have a job and
those people probably gonna have to be
your champions so you have to figure out
some way it's like this somehow eats a
lot of other time they want to do other
parts of their job or what have you and
you figure out some in-between on there
and usually I say like figure out some
kind of smart guess and just start with
your first customer and for Enterprise
pricing you can adjust and depending on
how fast they answer the question you're
gonna move the price up or down the
biggest thing is just start with some
kind of model one of the biggest
mistakes I think some companies do is
they start people off on free pilots
there's like oh just try using the
program we won't charge you anything
we'll try it for 60 or 90 days and we'll
figure out where we go from there and I
think that's a poor way of thinking
about stuff again you don't set yourself
up to figure out how to one map out the
organization to figure out like what is
it going to take to actually close you
don't beta test your pricing as
all these questions come near that you
just are kicking the can down the road
and so what I usually advise is say like
look we don't have free trials in our
company like we can provide a service
that is like a value here's what I can
do for you we start off with a
three-month plan it's gonna cost this
much money and if you are not satisfied
with the product or service one percent
money-back guarantee but you know in
that way you can play the safe but like
that way you have gone through the
actual process of like navigating
Enterprise pricing and payment and
accounting and legal and all that stuff
just to get to do that process and if
they say they're not even interested in
that so that means maybe that you don't
have a product that people actually want
to begin with the other one is to think
about incentives in terms of like your
sales force and also in terms of
people's reasons to buy and the best
model I've ever heard about this
actually came from filled of them from
Evernote and he actually talked about
concept that he learned from someone
else it was about the pricing
thermometer and the idea is that those
three numbers associated with like
pricing and so you have like the cost of
the product here you have the price of
the product and then you have the value
of the product and those are three
numbers associated a service or product
and it says that gap between the cost
and the price of the product that is
considered that gap in distance is
incentive to sell right so because it's
like oh for every one of these I sell
I'd make that much money as a company
the gap between value to price that is
incentive to buy for the customer right
and so where do you put the price on the
line controls where are the pressures
for buying and selling right and so for
example Evernote they charge $30 a year
and they've never changed that pricing
and the idea is like we want all the
energy around our software and service
to be incentive to buy right because
like wow this product all it sort of
offers has high value to me so it makes
me want to buy and there's enough people
and enough pressure on there it makes it
worth it and what's amazing about that
is if you can make that work it grows by
word of mouth and Organa
they don't need a huge sales force to
sell this because the value in itself
automatically makes the sales sort of
happen usually a lot of people want to
do is like figure out like how do I get
the price as close to value as possible
and then what you do is you destroy one
of those impulses for sort of people and
also the feedback like loop that you
generate for your salespeople is usually
pretty broken right because they'll do
anything to sort of sell it and and the
reason why people want to talk about it
it's completely different it's like yeah
it's gonna be really expensive you kind
of get what you pay for but I'm not
super excited about it and anyone that
is willing to increase that gap in the
other direction can undercut you as a
result and they undercut you not because
like oh if this is better priceless
because better value but also like now
there's two pressures in there to make
you want to like consume or upgrade or
what have you